- Oui!
- Ça va bien?
- Ça va très bien.
- Au fil des ans, Vania Aguilar
a rencontré cinq ministres
de l'Éducation pour leur parler
de l'urgence de reconstruire
l'école Irénée Lussier.
Cette école spécialisée est
dédiée aux jeunes de 12 à 21 ans
vivant avec une déficience
intellectuelle et de l'autisme.
Le fils de Madame Aguilar
a 25 ans aujourd'hui.
Des dizaines d'élèves comme lui
ont fréquenté un batiment
désuet, un labyrinthe de
couloirs, mal adapté à leurs
particularités sensorielles.
JOHANNE CHARTIER, éducatrice
ressource, école Irénée Lussier
- Le son, la résonance
des lieux. Il y a un élève qui
crie dans une classe au bout
du corridor, ça dérange
les élèves de la classe
de l'autre bout du corridor.
C'est toujours, toujours...
ces échos. Fait que
nos batiments ne sont vraiment
pas adaptés. Ce projet-là, avec
des larges corridors, il a été
pensé pour nos enfants.
- On va avoir des locaux adaptés
a nos enfants.
- Michel Bernier est le père
d'un garçon de 13 ans, un élève
d'Irénée Lussier.
MICHEL BERNIER, parent bénévole,
Conseil d'Étab., Irénée Lussier
- Ça demande beaucoup
de persévérance. C'est sûr
qu'il y a eu tous les enjeux
politiques, de changement
de ministres, etc. Et puis,
bien là, on arrive à
une finalité.
JEAN-FRANCOIS ROBERGE,
ministre de l'Éducation
- Harry et Gabriel, c'est pour
vous autres qu'on fait ça.
On est, disons, beaucoup plus
engagés pour débloquer
les sommes et pour faire avancer
le projet. Aujourd'hui,
on n'est pas en train d'élaborer
un concept; on inugure
un chantier qui est déjà
en marche.
- L'école toute neuve permettra
de passer de 190 élèves à 250,
réunis dans un lieu qui permette
aux jeunes d'acquérir les bases
d'une certaine autonomie
au quotidien.
RHÉAL LAUZON, directeur,
école Irénée Lussier
- Une cuisine, le jardin à
l'extérieur, tout ça pour
les amener à developper
cette chère autonoimmie.
Et l'école est grande,
donc les déplacements.
- Les croquis montrent
des espaces lumineux qui
plaisent à Gabriel et Harry.
- Oui, je suis content.
C'est très beau l'école,
c'est très beau
- Cette école spécialisée unique
au Centre de services scolaire
de Montréal rayonne bien au-delà
du quartier où elle est située.
ALEXANDRE LEDUC, député QS,
Hochelaga-Maisonneuve
- Ça a été long, trop long
bien sûr, comme tous les autres
projets qui attendent
dans le quartier Hochelaga
Maisonneuve, toutes les autres
écoles. Mais au final
aujourd'hui, c'est une bonne
nouvelle.
- Cette fois, on peut dire que
l'échéancier est coulé dans
le béton. Les élèves seront
accueillis ici dès l'automne
2023.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, M